oh wait happy st. tottering hams day or
belated mm-hmm I'm going to tell you
what it is you better know what the [ __ ]
it is and from now on you don't ever ask
that okay my equal [ __ ] my Lord
Commander yes my lord
just real quick I'm an Arsenal FC fan we
took second in the league that leagues
done the season's over but what happened
was Tottenham our direct rivals we're
ahead of us but the the point in the in
the year where we know the Arsenal knows
that they're gonna go ahead of Tottenham
it's called st. tottering hems day so in
this day of the year there's absolutely
no way Tottenham is going to surpass our
points or second place this for four
months ahead of us open to the last day
last game last Sunday and they lost we
won which put gave us a point ahead of
them it was the best day of my life
so Tottenham could have actually won for
the first beat us for the first time in
20 years yeah yeah yeah they almost fit
into the ladder more devastated by that
than anything else in the air
that's correct and losing the title
games yeah I love you guys
[Music]